this is a production of Cornell
University
today we'll be talking about hands-on
learning in horticulture but first and
Steve did point this out there we go um
we are in pen even though our name is
Delaware Valley we are in Pennsylvania I
put a big star up here for of course
this is Cornell we are down here in
Doylestown this is Bucks County
Pennsylvania this is Philadelphia and
interestingly enough we are just about
as far from Cornell as we are from Penn
State so I'm gonna be coming north
rather than west from now on so I can't
talk about hands-on learning and
teaching in horticulture without
discussing some of the work from Liberty
High Bailey
of course since I've been here I spent a
lot of time reading about Liberty hi
Bailey looking at all his portraits and
I thought this was particularly
interesting he wrote a book back in 1910
talked called the training of farmers
and he said I regard certain kinds of
demonstration work on farms as of the
greatest teaching value if it is
conducted by a good teacher and this
quote really struck home with me because
we we definitely use our teaching farms
at Del Vale we use the farms in region
and it's really important to the faculty
at del val to be good teachers we for
the most part do very little research we
are not we don't have to publish papers
most of us do not have big research
programs we don't have to unless we want
to apply for grants what we do is teach
and so and I'll talk about that through
the seminar so it's really important
also to know a little bit of about the
history of del val it was actually
founded in 1896 as the national farm
school and so this is this is Rabbi
Joseph Kraus coffe and this is actually
on one of the original buildings that is
now still honor
campus but what's really interesting is
how this all came about and believe it
or not there's actually connections to
Cornell in the history of del Val
so hopefully everybody recognizes Andrew
Dixon white here in about 1887 Joseph
Krause coughed was the the rabbi he was
the leader of a large Jewish synagogue
in Philadelphia called kinetise Israel
and krauskopf was really known as a
social reformer he was very
forward-thinking on the role of women on
the the need for for social programs and
he addressed these issues in his writing
he was again very well known at that
time in 1894 he actually wrote to Andrew
Dixon white who was the ambassador to
Russia okay and it was because of Andrew
Dixon white putting him in touch with
count Leo Tolstoy that Rabbi krauskopf
met with Leo Tolstoy and Tolstoy
actually told him return to America and
lead the tens of thousands from your
congested cities to your idle fertile
lands what krauskopf spoke to Tolstoy
about was his worries his concerns for
many of the Jewish immigrants coming to
the United States he was especially
worried about the Jewish youth coming
over and not having jobs and the the
anti-semitism that they were beginning
to see so again this was a seminal
moment in the in the genesis of del val
and krauskopf actually wrote about it in
my visit to Tolstoy interestingly the
friendship and this is just an aside the
friendship between Andrew Dixon white
and Joseph Krause cough continued in
1906 white actually
came to Philadelphia and he gave the
keynote speech a dedication of a stained
glass window that was being installed in
kanessa
Kenneth us-israel in Philadelphia this
is this is a photograph of that the
window was dedicated to the Secretary of
State John Hayes who apparently Andrew
Dixon white knew very well and in one of
the publications I was reading he gave a
wonderful speech about this and so this
friendship between krauskopf and Andrew
Dixon white continued for many years
I've actually well being on sabbatical
here at Cornell's have spent some time
in the archives down in Olin library
which is an amazing place and these are
some of the letters that I found this is
from these two set of correspondences
this is from Joseph Krause cough and
this is actually from Andrew Dixon white
it's a it's a multiple page letter back
to Krause cough and I I wanted to read
it's hard to for you to see right here
but you could tell that there was an
affection between the two men crossed us
says in his letter with kindest regards
to your dear wife and daughter who I had
the pleasure of meeting at our temple in
all of which mrs. Krause Cobb heartily
joins me I remain with sentiments of
esteem very Sincerely Yours Joseph cross
cough so there there was this connection
between dehl Val and Cornell but so
let's get back to teaching and learning
when krauskopf got back from Russia what
he did was he what he learned from
Tolstoy was that there should be science
with practice and so Krauss cough came
back and he bought hundreds of acres of
land in Bucks County Pennsylvania and
you can see an aerial photograph of what
it looks like and of course this is what
kind of a more modern schematic of what
campus looks like today from the hundred
or so
years that krauskopf started with he
bought more and more and more and over
the years del val has been gifted with
farms so we actually have a wealth of
acreage we have three separate farms and
over a thousand acres of farmland which
enforced land which we have orchards and
we have vegetable crops and animals and
pastures and everything that that an Ag
school might have so the National farm
school changed through the years in 1948
it became the natural National
Agricultural College in 1960 it actually
became Delaware Valley College of
Science and Agriculture somewhere along
the way they dropped the science and
agriculture and we were just for many
years Delaware Valley College we added
buildings and as again as I said we
added farms and it was in 2014 that the
college became a university and so what
we are today is about 1,700
undergraduates we have about 300
graduate students but all of our
graduate programs are in business and
education and we now have a couple of
smaller programs in criminal justice and
policy studies we actually do not have
graduate programs in any of the sciences
but there are about 25 majors and once
Daleville became a university we broke
up into three separate colleges so AG
and environmental sciences business in
humanities and life and physical
sciences and of course I am and part of
the AG and environmental science College
at Dell Vale so we have about 90 total
faculty which is really interesting and
as I understand that there's about 90
total faculty here in six at Cornell so
it's just been really wonderful to know
that that you know I'm surrounded by so
many people who love plants as much as
as much as I do so the science with prac
that historical way that Krauss
co-founded the National farm school has
stayed with us through all of these
years and all of these changes
historically so when I began in 2000
students had the requirements of working
900 hours in their field before they
could graduate and so over the years
that's changed slightly and we now have
what is called the e360 program or the
experience 360 program and a hundred
percent of our students graduate with
experience in the field that they want
to go into so you cannot major in
something without having worked in that
field and along with the actual work
experience we have classes that go along
with a 360 that that require that the
students actually reflect on their work
experiences so it's not just doing a job
it's reflecting on wow did I like this
job just my personality suited to this
job is this something I think I can do
long term so it's really developed into
an entire program and the experience is
that the the student received through
this e360 program actually go on their
transcripts so it's something that they
can present to an employer part of the
work experience that Daleville students
are required to have can be done on
campus and I think this is one of the
things I've noted that might be a little
different than here is we have we have a
few farm managers but by and large the
work on the farms is done by student
employees and so these are actually
students who are working we have
orchards we have a apple sorting
equipment we have a cider press and so
the students are the ones who are
working on the farms providing much of
the
that's needed to keep all this acreage
going in the plant sciences at Del Vale
we are actually split up into two
different departments and similarly to
what has happened here you know there's
been this this change in our we one
department are we two are we three but
right now this is where we are I'm in
the Department of Plant Sciences we have
around a hundred and five students and
we have majors in all of these areas so
there's a horticulture major a
sustainable AG major a turf major crop
science and then our organic farming
certificate which I'll talk about in a
few minutes
landscape architecture and environmental
sciences is just a little bit smaller
and you can major in environmental
science you can actually do a landscape
architecture degree which we have a
Delvaux alum who is here now getting her
mla and our program is an accredited
landscape architecture program which is
really has been a benefit since the
student who's here now was able to cut a
semester out of her program because of
coming through this program we have lots
of different facilities on campus one of
the things that's really popular and
this is actually part of the
horticulture major is we have both
hydroponics and aquaponics on campus and
and we were able to retrofit some of our
greenhouses because of an extremely
large for us donation and so this now is
somewhere that students work there's a
class around this and then the lettuce
that produce is produced shows up in our
cafeteria we also have as I mentioned
lots of trees the campus itself is
considered to be the Henry Schneider
Arboretum and so almost all of our trees
and our shrubs are laid
so you you know what everything is in an
in our Arbor culture class students are
actually taught so this is this is a
class this is an actual student they're
taught to climb trees and and which is
is something that someone who going out
into the world to be an arbor
culturalist might need to know and then
are generally in our laes department
what we are involved in is the
Philadelphia Flower Show which is every
March it's one of the largest flower
shows in the country and there's actual
class that students take in the fall
semester where they design the display
for the Flower Show and then in the
spring semester they actually build as
much as they can on campus and then are
responsible for taking it down to Philly
to the convention center and assembling
and painting and doing everything but
the display needs advising is also
really important at so avail one of the
things that we have in place is it's
called a hold on the student accounts a
student cannot register for classes
unless they've seen their advisor and
what that means is that when once the
advisor has met with the student then we
go into a system online and release the
hold and the student is able to register
it's that important for us to have this
one-on-one contact with the student
every single semester so I advise and it
varies we added two new faculty a couple
years ago it's been as many as 30 but
now it hovers around probably 12 to 15
so it gets really busy during advising
season all right so we are a unionized
teaching institution and what that means
is we are actually contractually
obligated to teach twelve contact hours
each semester so this is actually this
is what I'm heading
back to white this is what I was so
great to be on sabbatical this is what I
missed so and so this is a lecture in
lab this is a lecture lecture this is a
lecture and a lab I just teach the
lecture portion and this is just more of
a almost like a a discussion section I
thought it'd be kind of interesting to
show everyone this is my schedule this
is what so we actually are obligated to
in fact this was really funny when I
came here I'm like where's everyone's
schedule on their door we have to put
this on our door this is so that
everybody knows not only where we are
but where we can be found because again
advising is such a critical piece of
this this hands-on this close
relationship we have with students the
other thing I wanted the other thing I
wanted to point out was that we schedule
in a way that helps us do this hands-on
learning so for example commercial
vegetable production has a lecture on
Monday but it also has a lecture and a
lab on Wednesday so I have a good 4
hours with the students in order to take
them on trips and do longer types of
projects IPM is there is no lab but the
lectures are scheduled back-to-back so
we in this case we have like about a 3
hour time frame that allows us to do a
little more oh and last thing is we are
also again contractually obligated to
have six office hours per week and so
these are these are times that we have
to be in our office and available to
students
alright so finally to the really fun and
interesting part what I actually get to
do when I teach horticulture it's oval
so this is the marketing of
horticultural products class this class
once again is really is required of
horticulture majors because a lot of our
students are going back to family
businesses or they're going to have
their own farms and so in this case we
take about four to five field trips each
semester the students are creating new
businesses and in this regard
it's a horticultural business they have
to actually have business cards they
create brochures they have an online
newsletter they write press releases in
some cases the students are actually
creating real businesses so it's pretty
exciting when they actually have
something that they're going to use
later on the end of the semester is what
we call shark tank and they're actually
doing presentations as if they were in
shark tank so that they can get
experience looking for business loans
some of our field trips are awesome it's
a little dark here but this is actually
the Philadelphia regional wholesale
produce market it is an amazing
state-of-the-art place it is the largest
refrigerated terminal market in the
world and if you have not been there I
would highly recommend a trip there it
does not break the cold chain so it's
very different than Hunts Point Market
we also visit farms in this case this is
an entertainment farm they have the
bouncing pillows and the pea so this is
like an open moon bounce and the farmers
are insistent that if the students try
that so they get a chance once again to
really get a feel for what it's like to
have an entertainment farm in organic
food and fiber which is a fall class we
take field trips again probably about
four every semester one of them is to
the Rodale Institute which as you'll see
is our partner in the organic farming
certificate program it's about an hour
from Del Val we visit various organic
farms this is a particular farm this is
a an organic grocery store that's about
20 minutes from campus but one of the
neatest things that we do is the student
are actually involved in the organic
certification inspection that takes
place on one of our farms for many years
I was responsible for maintaining the
certification so what I will do is I'll
haul all my organic system plan and
documentation to class the students
actually get to see that and then this
is our inspector we go through the
inspection on the farm and then they
actually sit through the the exit
interview which is part of every organic
inspection this has been a really
wonderful exercise because of having so
many students who want to have organic
farms so often there is this curtain
behind what it means to be certified
organic and this exercise really opens
the curtain and shows everyone that it's
not a process that is is is terrible to
go through by any means the other thing
that we do again because organic food
and fiber has to deal with animals as
well we get in some guest lectures this
is a cow signals workshop and so we
actually are down in a dairy farm on
campus which you can just walk to and
the organic veterinarian is leading this
is actually a student he's leading the
students through an exercise looking at
cow signals which is a way to keep
cattle healthy when you are an organic
producer commercial vegetable production
which I've really enjoyed sitting in on
Steve's class we have a lab attached to
ours and one of the biggest things we do
is what's called the farmers apprentice
project in one of our greenhouses on
campus we have 12 raised beds each
raised bed is 40 square feet and so the
student and their partner raise
vegetables all semester and so it starts
out the beds start out empty or with
just you can see
the beginnings of the plantings we do
have lights in the greenhouse so this
helps in January and February when
there's really not enough outdoor light
but you can see that it becomes a jungle
in here and students really take
ownership of producing their crops they
love that they are able to harvest and
take everything home and eat what
they've actually produced not only bad
but they're doing scouting they're doing
pest control and one of the most
important things that they do in this
project is record keeping as anyone
knows today whether you're organic or
whether a conventional farmer because of
food safety concerns and traceability
every farmer needs to have good records
and so this is a this really trains them
in record-keeping absolutely everything
they're doing from what varieties
they've chosen to plant to what types of
pests or what types of pest control
measures they've done this is something
that students really enjoy and if you're
ever feeling gloomy on a March day you
just find people wandering in here
because it just becomes this wonderful
jungle of vegetable crops we do take
field trips in our commercial veg class
this is an alumni farm del val is
actually across the street from burpies
ford hook farm which is a really
beautiful place to go so we've gone to
Fort Hood farm this is jr. Peters it's a
fertilizer company about an hour from
Del Vale this is Kerry Peters and this
is Krystal Snyder crystals and alum and
so she hosts us at this amazing
fertilizer facility and so the students
actually get to see fertilizer being
blended and bagged and some of the
testing that they do with that facility
as well often times farms will they will
have exercises for the student or tasks
for the students to do so we've we've
done everything
from planting to digging the holes for
irrigation all kinds of different things
we're a little over an hour from hers
potato chip factory so we will sometimes
take field trips to hers where we meet
with gene her one of the owners and
operators who does all the potato buying
for the the chipping that goes on at
hers and the tour is just really fun
because of course they pull the fresh
potato chips off the conveyor belt for
everyone to taste and then Lester
wondering why I have a chocolate world
photo here this is because one of the
field trips that's so important to us in
commercial vegetable production is the
going to the Mid Atlantic fruit and
vegetable growers convention in Hershey
Pennsylvania vegetable growers has been
gracious enough to let our students in
for free this has been going on for as
long as I as long as I've been there and
so we go on our class day it's a
Wednesday we take a bus and del Val used
to have their own buses but we now rent
through a service but we go to Hershey
for the day and students are able to get
in they're able to experience what a
grower meeting is all about they go to
talks and then every now and then if we
have extra time we stop at chocolate
world so we do labs on campus similar to
what Steve has done we get students it's
we get students out on equipment we get
them planting laying plastic we're
planting potatoes sometimes we are able
to take advantage of what's happening on
our farms so in years past students have
actually helped build a high tunnel and
so it's I'm usually in pretty close
contact with our farm managers and if
something's going on and it fits into
our schedule in their schedule we try to
jump into this this is one of our high
tunnels that we actually plant and the
students are able to actually set up the
trickle irrigation
system so they get that kind of hands-on
way to do the plumbing and with the
headers and so on and so forth I also
teach a lab on grafting and so our the
students are taught three different ways
to graft Tomatoes
and so they do the grafting exercise and
then we monitor the progress on whether
the graft has been successful or not
throughout the remainder of the semester
IPM I wanted to include a class that
doesn't have a lab if you recall this is
scheduled so we have a long course
period we take a couple of field trips
that are really valuable you you may
remember Lloyd and Alex Traven from
Pease tree farms they are Cornell alums
they have a certified organic greenhouse
but they use all beneficial insects and
IPM practices in the greenhouse and this
is one of the most eye-opening field
trips for the students because they see
that you can have this immaculate
greenhouse full of many different
species of plants and have very very low
pest pressure through the use of
biological controls the the New Jersey
beneficial insect lab is an amazing
place in fact it's probably the next to
Steve is the best thing about New Jersey
yep this is part of New Jersey's
Department of Agriculture they actually
raise beneficial insects there it is
very unique there are not labs like this
around the country this is only one of a
handful and we take students there and
they're very welcoming they show us the
lab they show us how they raise their
beneficial insects and some of the
projects that they are they've been
involved in students also do what's
called an IPM toolbox it's a very
lengthy project broken up into pieces
but again they're able to choose a crop
and they come out with a set of
information that they take with them
when they're working in a greenhouse
when they're working on a farm and so
the the IPM toolbox as big of a project
as it is I always get very positive
comments that students have enjoyed
doing this and taking this deep dive
into what IPM really means for their
specific crop um I would be remiss if I
didn't actually talk about assessment
and student engagement I've spent a lot
of time here at Cornell looking over
your Center for teaching innovation
website and I think that we are I think
we're doing what we're supposed to be
doing in Daleville which was really a
nice thing to see and so we have a lot
of time for discussion one of the things
that I do is that there's actually
questions about the field trip on the
exams so these field trips don't just
exist because they're enjoyable to get
off campus they're tested on what they
learn students are encouraged to take
notes to take pictures and to integrate
what they've learned on the farm into
any project that they're doing the e360
program again students are employed
they're working they're encouraged to
provide feedback on whether learning has
taken place so again I believe that
we're doing what we should be doing as
far as all of the teaching and learning
research that's been done lastly I just
have a few more slides on one of our
most hands-on programs not a class but a
program is our organic farming
certificate program we are partnered
with the Rodale Institute and we've
actually been supported by to USDA
beginning farmer and rancher development
grants really exciting at this point in
my career I'm finally getting grants
which is so but it has been a whole
learning experience for me
we have about 75% veterans in this
program but they're integrated right
into our regular classes which has been
a real challenge
from a teaching and learning perspective
they're spending the summer session
though at Rodale where they have two
other academic classes and then the the
farm practicum is essentially our
version of this e3 60 they're actually
working on a farm and then we have a
class period where everyone reflects on
the work they're doing and shares what
they're doing and everybody kind of gets
to to learn from that this is an awesome
hands-on thing that I'm able to do this
is global field studies and so I do
teach a course every other year in
gardens food food and farms in Tuscany
you really can't learn about Italian
food without going to Italy and and so
so we take or I should say I take
students and we go to this amazing farm
called spin akhiya and I would truly if
anyone here wants to take students I
would highly recommend this place it's
awesome they are set up with places like
almost like dorms for students to live
in they produce all the food that they
serve they have classes right there so
this is something that again hands-on
learning not only about horticulture but
about the culture of Italy and the there
the way they approach food so that's a
lot of fun as well and then lastly our
clubs and our organizations also reflect
the hands-on philosophy of Deauville I'm
the advisor of ort Society which is our
horticulture Club and so we take field
trips to of course see mushrooms which
Philadelphia is the mushroom capital of
the US and we're not far from a
cranberry farm and which I was saying to
someone this morning the if and I'm
inviting you all to come out next fall
the farmer actually has a whole set of
hip waders and so everybody puts on hip
waders and goes into the cranberry bog
which is awesome and then we also take
groups of students to another conference
Sylvania Association for sustainable
agriculture which has been historically
held at Penn State but now it's gonna be
in Lancaster so it's even closer all
right so my time is just about up and I
just want to once again thank everyone
here at Cornell for being so welcoming
I've had such a wonderful sabbatical I
came across this poem from Liberty High
Bailey and I felt like it's really
important for me to finish with this I'm
gonna read this because it it's about
the way that Liberty High Bailey thought
we should be teaching and the way I
believed in teaching so there certainly
will come a day as men become simple and
wise when schools will put their books
away till they train the hands and eyes
then the school from its heart will say
in love of the wind and the skies I
teach the earth and the soil to them
that toil the hill and fun to common men
that live just here so thank you
everybody I'd be happy to answer any
questions so the question was when do I
schedule the longer field trips so the
Italy trip because it's horticultural in
nature I go in September and I always
schedule it over the Labor Day it's ten
days so we I schedule it over the Labor
Day weekend and so the students are
missing like a little bit less and also
because it's so early in the semester we
actually start about a week later than
Cornell starts we're usually in about
the second week of the semester so
students aren't really big they're
missing classes but it's it's they can
catch up they have a lot of time to
catch up
No
um we are that's a no that's a great
question to other faculty get upset
because students are missing classes I
would honestly tell you that we are so
everyone does lots of trips and field
trips you get used to it it's something
that is part of the Daleville culture
that everyone just is accepting if
somebody we have a very active FFA group
and they usually go for a whole week you
just you just help the student catch up
and provide as much support material as
you can through blackboard and
everything else so that the student you
know as I said is missing as little as
possible so UT of classes I'm wondering
thank you so much I asked when I took a
risk I think that the I think that the
the biggest risk I felt was teaching IPM
just because I had a very coming out of
graduate school I had a very strong
background in weed science but not so
much in entomology and plant pathology I
mean the background that everyone
typically has but um I feel like IPM is
the class that I've I've developed the
most and am very very successful at
teaching and so yes I think it I took
some risks with that but also then I was
um very early on I also started
promoting the whole idea of beneficial
insects and using bio controls and I
think everyone now can say wow this is
there's so much going on in that area so
that's where I would say yes taking
taking a risk of teaching is that's
where that was Don Jackie first thank
you so much for your seminar and for
sharing LH Bailey's home that home was
very reflective
is engagement with the nature studies
which also featured people I get a box
for Comstock and Louie Ghazis my
question is can you talk a bit about the
demographics of your students where they
come from what their backgrounds are
like yes thank you Don the demographics
of our students and that's a good that's
an excellent question the majority of
our students are from Pennsylvania and
New Jersey and then the mid-atlantic
region many of our students are still
first-generation college students and
they and they are by and large from
rural backgrounds so their high school
preparation for college is certainly not
as strong as you would find in a Cornell
student also our average SATs although
in horticulture is fairly high in
general for for Daleville as a whole is
significantly lower than the typical the
typical Cornell student so so while not
everyone is from a farm they're
generally from a rural community in the
mid-atlantic region and so they want to
go back to that community and and and
have some sort of career in in
agriculture also I should make note we
we do not send very many students to
graduate school I would say 5% of our
graduates go on to graduate school maybe
10% but but really very very few so
these are people who are going into the
agricultural industry working in
greenhouses we do a really good job
placing students at Longwood Gardens and
Delvaux students are known I think
historically for being able to hit the
ground running when they start their
employment because they've had such a
such a hands-on type of training on so
much job experience Hannah
so almost all of our um almost arbor
Hannah's question was what our summers
like at Dell Val for four faculty
they're awesome I would be lying if I
didn't say that
but for students some students will stay
and work on the farm at Dell Vail this
past summer we actually had something
new since we're so close to burpees Fort
Hood farm we actually they wanted to
give their round a rest
so all of their trial gardens moved over
to del val so we had a number of interns
working on the trial gardens this summer
there's also just a group who works with
production we have what's called a hope
for the harvest garden a charitable
garden where we just produce four to
give away to fill abundance it's a local
food charity but most students will go
back to where they're from and and find
some sort of because they're generally
from an agricultural region they'll find
some sort of job that will count towards
their e3 60 credits yes so the question
is do students go through the
tree-climbing certification program I
don't know exactly if they do but we
tend to have a lot of in that because I
don't teach that class but we tend to
have a lot of add-ons in our class so
there's a course where that you can take
that you get your pesticide applicators
license and then in the past and I
haven't done this recently because but
in the past some of my classes have
actually counted towards the credits
that you need to keep renewing your
pesticide applicators license so we do
try to have add-ons like that as much as
possible all right so I can't wait you
know and I actually that's a again a
great are there things I've seen here
yes there absolutely are and
bencao very helpful in the plant anatomy
class
alejandro nixon flips the classroom and
i'm going to i'm gonna do that we're
going to integrate that into the botany
lab which I've been working on revising
a botany lab manual Steve and his
vegetable production does the
problem-solving which has I think is
excellent because it really it it gives
the students an opportunity to actually
talk to the class about you know
questions and what type of what they're
seeing in the field so yes that and then
Marvin I love the idea of the
e-portfolio and I'd love to bring
something like that back to del Val
so we'll see all right Annie oh yes one
more I'm back yes so the question is how
like how much leeway do you have for
developing new and innovative you can we
have a lot of leeway if there's
something that you want to teach then
you are encouraged to develop a new
course around that so for example we
have someone who just was hired about
two years ago from University of
California Davis is a she's a plant
breeder and she's developed a new crop
evolution class we have someone else who
is interested in medicinal plants they
just developed that new class someone
else her global field studies classes
she took students to Hawaii last spring
break so she developed not only the
Hawaii trip but a lecture class around
that so that's that's because we're not
doing research we're really encouraged
to do that type of scholarship for our
promotion and tenure packages our
portfolios it's the scholarship of
teaching that is really what has to come
through loud and clear so developing new
classes is
part of that and then there's also a set
of one credit honors colloquia that are
usually available to teach if you want
to try something out just one lecture a
week you can do but take that path as
well all right thank you everyone this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu